so
your situation are you on probation are
you totally yeah i'm on probation but
not i don't got to check in or nothing
so it's not it's unsupervised yeah
pretty much how long how long five years
five that's a long time in it
five years it's crazy that [ __ ] is damn
a long time but at least it's
unsupervised yeah
when everything opens back up hopefully
that you know that i don't know
is it gonna be the type of probation
where you gotta get permission to leave
the state type [ __ ]
i mean yeah but i don't think they
tripping like that
because they weren't even tripping
before they just want me to get
catch a charge that's what they want i
don't think they tripping on nothing
like that
yeah hopefully they just kind of moved
on like all right you know what we tried
yeah
pretty much i would hope we got to let
them out now yeah
i know they watching me though for sure
you're watching me yeah just be smart
man you know casanova's just got those
ricoh chargers man i've seen that
i've seen g herbal g herb had to turn
himself in on some fraud [ __ ]
but that rico nothing for that time yeah
but the rico [ __ ]
yeah that that's like the six nine [ __ ]
i does oh that's life that carry life
yo i gotta get your perspective you know
it's funny because you mentioned six
nine
i gotta just get your perspective as as
because you were in jail throughout his
whole
his whole entire [ __ ] yeah like
the highs yeah you're getting locked up
and then he'll get out and snitching
like crazy like like that [ __ ] is
it's crazy to even fathom that that
even happened i mean but what do you
expect from a [ __ ] rainbow hair bro
that's funny though i know i give it he
was funny i liked it he mastered the it
was funny
no one has mastered the internet and the
trolling better now mind you he was
doing some dangerous [ __ ]
he was but you can't you can't do that
you can only do that
to a certain extent you can do all that
if you're really from the streets and
you really like a street [ __ ]
but if you're not like that it's gonna
always come back to bite you
like me out from the streets i talk [ __ ]
that's cool
but whatever i'm not in the same
position as him
he had to pay people you know type of
[ __ ] to hang around him i don't pay
people to hang around me
i grew up with all these people right
right um so it's different
i'm these people's ticket out of the
game so i don't think people want to
play with me like that but i'm not
nobody like when you say that there's a
lot of people
who who unfortunately they do have to
come to la yeah and they have to pay
attacks yeah for sure right i'm not one
of those people but that's only like out
of town or people no i'm saying
they got to check in i mean that that's
anywhere though but we i guess i'll hear
it just stricter like
i want to ask you this right because
does everyone need to check in or only
people who have that street persona when
they come to l.a
you're like a gangster rapper and you
come to l.a or detroit you got to check
in with certain people yeah pretty much
but if it's like logic like there's a
lot like logic does probably doesn't
like your opponents i'm pretty sure
they're going to get up on them too
right
now if you're somebody like dirk or thug
or somebody on they're not going for
that right right right
right but all these other people oh yeah
they got to play
i think i think too like a lot of people
don't realize like yo man like
you can't just let your guard down out
here you can't no matter
you know rest in peace to pop smoke yeah
like he was in the hills bro
yeah exactly good kids can't trust
nobody can't trust nobody bro
and and a lot of people we've lost since
you've been locked up
yeah ex like lots of people i like that
[ __ ]
and uh i think you know
for for you you know being on probation
and and and
i think it's dope that you got a second
james man pretty much it seems like you
got your
your you know you got your head in the
right place
to go on a big run pretty much yeah i
mean i don't got nothing to do anybody
but to record there's nothing nowhere to
go
so all i can do is make music and since
i'm independent i'm gonna get all that
money
so yeah there it is